you can see just for my own sake it gets
no marks this line especially since you
have a reference sheet but I should
point out I did this without a reference
sheet and this is not that hard a
formula to learn I mean this top part
here just looks like general form of the
equation of a straight line and then
this part down here is Pythagoras it
just looks like that's where it comes
from
okay so you can see I've written it down
so that when I am putting in all of the
numbers I don't screw it up so I know
what numbers I'm putting into where so
this is the result I came up with after
I did all of my absolute value what have
you do I have an agreement yeah cool
looks good
the next question down here is a couple
of different ways to do it here's the
way I approached it I looked at line L
and I said I want a line that's
perpendicular to line O so unlike in the
first case where I put the equation of
the line in general form this time I put
the equation of a line in this form what
is this one this is gradient
intercept slope intercept and the reason
why is because I'm after this guy right
here okay so I have pulled out that
gradient and I use that to find the
gradient of the line it's perpendicular
to that it's just the negative
reciprocal as you can see on the right
hand side once you've got that I launch
straight into here Michael question yep
it absolutely is because I haven't that
to my eyes I'm going to be where perfect
so you can see as well what's important
is that I don't have to use many words
but the words are very descriptive and
tell you exactly what the working means
Eric you're talking about this part here
yeah sure figure question in terms of
things that you might want to skip over
I think that gets a pass on the
condition that number one you can get
that very quickly and number two you can
get it accurately
now just personally my own brain I don't
trust it I don't feel like I've gained
any time by actually it
during this first step here and there is
a chance I mean you didn't get any kind
of like value for this question you
didn't know how many marks it was worth
so that would give you more cues as to
whether you needed to include that
working or not personally I always just
include more working rather than less
because I always think that's the safe
option and also give me a reason to come
back if I'm checking and I'm like was
that the right number or not well I have
working that helps me understand whether
it was right or wrong okay
so the short answer your question is yes
but at your own risk
okay all right that you come down to
here now again as with most questions
there's a few different ways that you
could have set this out
it does say find and again I didn't put
a mark on it so had it we've been just
one there's a good chance you could have
just given a nitrate or would have
worked you can see the way I've set it
out I've taken advantage of this
identity here which is really the
definition of cosign right the co of
course stands for compliment it's the
compliment aside there's the compliment
right there okay so having done that I
can say that college seventy side twenty
and then I can replace called 70 with
sine of X plus five because that's what
exactly the question says it's worth
pointing out as I've written down the
bottom right hand side that there are
plenty of other solutions for example of
15 is a solution then what's another
solution you could probably think about
it if if I've got sine of fifteen plus
five degrees right that gives me my
twenty sine 20 but there's a lot of
different things that are equal to sine
20 a lot of different angles that give
you that
for instance sine of 380 will give you
the same value assigned 20 why is that
yeah adding 360 works because sine is a
periodic function it's periodic every
360 degrees so I could have come up with
an infinite number of solutions apart
from that but this is just a smallest
one okay thumbs up yep
let's go to the next one
like ah I wouldn't I'm gonna encourage
you to put some working because like I
said I haven't told you the value of
this I could totally have made that a
tune our question and you would have
been working it okay okay so here's my
next one can I get your hand so you got
this region ends up straight a bit
higher so I can really sit down half of
you okay think your hands down let me
talk you through it so you get given two
inequalities here's the first one and
here's the second one and I want to know
when both of those inequalities exist at
the same time so I draw them both and
then I want to look for the overlap you
can see I've got my circle there you'll
also notice that even though the
inequality that goes with the circle has
the boundary included you'll note that I
have drawn it dotted anyway for most of
it anyway why did I do that do you
remember back to why I did that
okay I need I need both to be true at
the same time so I don't know anything
while I'm drawing that circle I don't
know anything about the straight line
and what it's going to influence the
whole inequality so therefore being that
I don't know I leave it dotted it's
always easy to go back over that and
make it a whole line if I need to but if
I draw it a full line it's hot it's a
pain to rub out a whiteout or whatever
so I drew it dotted I did the same thing
to y equals x minus 2 and it reads
really important by the way that you
include those labels there then were you
a question so you're talking about doing
something like that yes absolutely so
this answer would be perfect however in
practice had I had a pencil rather than
you know a screen I would have shaded
that inside of the circle I was shaded
that bit underneath the line and there's
no reason to get rid of it if it's clear
like I think this is as to what's the
actual region that I'm describing is my
final answer
does that make sense so you don't have
to get rid of it so I'm saying once I've
got those two there you can see here is
the overlap and then I fill in this
boundary down here you see this one's
building why is that
it's what intersect but importantly that
that brought alone that arc we have
worthless right that arc satisfies both
inequalities it satisfies this top one
here because right on the boundary and
the boundaries included it also
satisfies this one because that portion
of the circle is beneath the straight
line does that make sense you might also
have worked out by the way why I said
don't worry about these points of
intersection they do need to be labeled
as hollow or filled a little filled but
as a little excess for us now if I
hadn't have told you to not worry about
it if I had just left it open you would
have had to found this point how do you
do that how do you find out where they
are
I need the point of intersection how do
I find point through intersection I saw
simultaneously now maybe just if you've
got some space you can draw it on your
friends if you like because you all have
the same thing just watch what happens
when I start to do this I'm solving
between let's put it up here x squared
plus y squared equals 9 that's per
circular boundary and y equals x minus 2
that's the straight line boundary so
when I solve this simultaneously if you
take equation 2 and substitute it into
equation 1 you get this do you agree
I've just done a straight section
wherever Y was I put in X minus 2 when
you have a look at this guy here what
are we going to get you're going to have
what - 2 sorry 4 X plus 4 yes equals 9
over on the right hand side and if you
collect all your like turns nice and
neatly I think you end up with this deal
great do you see why I told you not to
worry about this because this is not the
point of the question you're going to
get some ugly sides out of this then
you're gonna have to put them back into
this equation to find the y coordinate
this is not the point of the question I
just want to understand if you can work
out how these inequalities relate to
each other okay let's keep going see
it's my use of the cosine rule now did
you have to draw a diagram No
you've probably given a simplicity the
question could have worked it out and
done all of this working on the
right-hand side without the diagram
there but I don't see any reason why you
wouldn't like it took me all of five
seconds to draw that even with the stick
figure and I clearly know what I'm
working out and that's very helpful
okay significantly Paul significantly in
the cosine rule the only thing that
really matters is which is the size is
opposite the angle you're after because
we treat that side differently right
there is eight squared right you
subtract it and he doesn't make his way
onto the denominator did you agree with
the angle yep thumbs up so we can move
on from that forty five point two I put
it to wonderful voice because I didn't
have any particular accuracy have a look
at this guy now a plus or minus hundred
twenty degrees now you may have had a
quadrants diagram drawn here which would
have been fine if you did this via
quadrants which quadrants would you
determine the answer would be in okay so
you want to be over here look here and
here quadrants two and three however
we're so used to the quadrants being not
to 90 92 180 180 to 270 and 270 to 360
because that's what most questions are
from north to 360 but that's not what
the domain is here the domain is
different so in fact rather than these
two quadrants being these angles what
are the two quadrants corresponding to
yeah very good I'd probably say from
smaller the greater I'd say negative
ninety to zero that's the the closest
one and then negative 180 to negative 19
okay now that's perfectly fine you can
see the angle I'm going to get in here
is minus 120 and the angle I get up here
is positive 120 but it's just as easy to
argue that from the graph and your
calculator or if you you know I can't
remember your exact values your
calculator will simply hand back to you
120 degrees when you do this and from
the graph you can see the symmetry
sign is an even function remember even
functions I've got that symmetry there
so if 120 is an answer then widest 120
is also an answer